works later this evening it will include
you know the names of the chapters you
were to read and of the units and
bridging world history online I wanted
to look at but it will not include all
readings that might be assigned although
it will list just the first reading the
one from my book on animals on Sunday
you will receive notification about
sectioning and then say the the times
and the places of the sections and it
will be first come first serve still
working out some TA issues but they
should be fixed by then my section for
graduate students is going to be on
Thursdays it wasn't this week I sorry a
couple of people misunderstood that
starting next week and it will be
Thursday from 10 to 11 in in my office
in 421 unless there are too many people
so can I have a show of hands how many
graduate students once again 1 2 3 4 5 6
of that 7 that should easily not easily
that should be accommodated all within
my office so we'll meet there in 421 Oh
all right this is a week for chapter 1
chapter 1 deals with the entire history
of the species up to the Neolithic
Revolution and then whips to the Neal
after Revolution to the first supposedly
the first River Valley civilizations
investor taymiyah and Egypt in the last
class I sort of debunked the idea that
you could learn anything from big
history but somehow you do have to to
think about all the things involved with
the peopling of the world over a period
of tens of thousands of years
particularly in as much as that time
span encompasses a variety of
significant climatic shifts that make it
very difficult to recover exactly what
the experience was like for humans as
they moved into new habitats there are
some things that we can tell from from
bones and from implements one of them is
that the hominid teeth becomes smaller
and these are primarily the grinding
teeth and this is interpreted as a shift
to a diet that does not require so much
grinding of hard vegetable matter
therefore there's a there's been a
tendon clusion that as hominids move out
of Africa they eat more more soft foods
presumably meat this is also accompanied
by a reduction apparently in the extent
of the intestinal tract again seeming to
to allow for a meat diet I know this may
come as a disappointment to the vegans
in the room who are convinced that no
since Adam and Eve did not eat meat
therefore vegan culture has been the
natural paradisiacal state of humankind
but in fact we seem to have abundant
evidence that tremendous amounts of meat
were eaten I say up in terms of rapport
ssin of the diet why would this be the
case it actually makes a great deal of
sense if you are stranded in a place
that you have never been in before let
us say you know you were on an airplane
that came down on an island somewhere in
the South Seas that has never been
located and at the end you had to
survive fortunately there were pigs
there but but the question is what can
you eat in the vegetable world what we
know is that big proportion of the
plants either you cannot digest or they
taste awful or they poison you a small
percentage of them get you high and
therefore there's abundant reason to
keep trying
and you really have to visualize
particularly for Central and South
America where the number of psychotropic
plants identified by pre-columbian
peoples was in the hundreds you have to
imagine you know you and you know you
and your roommate going out in the
jungle and saying I'm gonna need this
leaf and if I die say something over my
grave and but if I don't die and then
report back what I ate and if I don't
die I'll tell you what it was like and
they end up getting I think you have to
realize that getting stoned was a major
social goal
cultural goal for humans in certain
parts of the world over substantial
periods of time and in a sense where
we're recovering the pristine nature of
humankind today not not me I'm too old
um any signs I'm a tenured professor at
Columbia I would do something like that
so so so if you can't just go out and
pick up things to eat from trees and
root in the ground and so forth what you
can do is eat an animal almost all flesh
is edible
it's one of the curious things about
animals now it's true that you want to
you know avoid certain poisonous animals
a particularly Blowfish but even there
the fish is good it's just the poison
part of it that's bad but it is likely
that when humans spread from one habitat
to another it took time for them to
learn what plants they could eat but
they could immediately eat the animals
so one of the things that you can think
about is that the the spread of hominids
to other to other parts of the world
is correlated some degree with this
shift toward toward meat-eating then
that brings the problem of how do you
eat meat oh I used to ask this in my
history of domestic animals course I
said well how would you go about eating
an animal and you know the football girl
says it why I take it by the horns do
this break its neck say okay now you've
killed it
now what do you do how do you get inside
and once you're inside what parts do you
eat you certainly don't chew on muscle
say well they're soft parts like
eyeballs and testicles in the liver and
so forth and by and large it seems
likely that all the parts of people
avoid now are the ones that were
preferred early on but even so
meat-eating probably began more as
scavenging the the bodies left by other
primates or other carnivores predators
rather than humans going out and killing
things on their own although as they
move in a new habitats killing on their
own becomes more and more important if
in fact they are eating more and more
meat in the Mesolithic period where you
have fully fledged Homo sapiens sapiens
rather than Neanderthals or other not
quite up to date modern forms of
humanity you have a big increase I
mentioned this last time in leading of
fish so you extend the diet but you
extend it toward other animal products
and then over time you you learn what
plants are edible within your
environment although for many of the
humans who settled in or who ranged over
Europe
Asia there was very little in the way of
edible plant cover this was Tundra that
simply did not have a very broad
spectrum of of edible foods plant foods
all right the Neolithic Revolution is
the introduction is seemingly of
large-scale consumption of specific
specific plants as I've said there's
this problem about why it is that that
grass seed is the one that seems to have
the biggest impact this there there's no
clear answer to this although one of the
answers probably has to do with the
number of inches prove rainfall that you
that you need for tubers and rhizomes
you know big fat starchy things that
grow underground
most of the edible species require
something around 30 inches of rain per
year whereas cereal grains can grow in
about eight inches of rain per year and
indeed the definition of the Fertile
Crescent which is often I used to talk
about the first areas supposedly the
first areas of of grain production is
the the line of 8-inch rainfall that
runs along the the highland areas of
Israel up into the coastal areas of
Syria across southern Turkey and down
along the mountains of western Iran the
if you had an arid zone as you have now
in which you had heavy rainfall in
tropical areas and comparatively heavy
rainfall in temperate areas much farther
north
let us say you a lot of rainfall in the
Congo and you know plenty of rainfall in
Scotland but somewhere in between you
have a band that's very very dry
spreading the the dependence on crops or
on wild plants that are that are
dependent upon substantial rainfall
across that zone would be very difficult
so for the for the temperate norm
northern climates it's not particularly
surprising that a seed plant like wheat
or barley would be more likely to spread
than yams or manioc or something like
that all right this this is enough what
is a fairly tedious subject let me shift
- not from the history of archeology to
the archaeology of history when history
conceptualization gets packaged in the
form of books or courses or simply a
received wisdom or documentaries or
something like that it reflects not
simply the recurrent perceptions of the
of the author's or makers but it
reflects the accumulation of of
discoveries or theories or accepted
stories that go back for a very long
period of time and of course the one
that we're going to start with here
a river valley civilization in
Mesopotamia and Egypt has a very long
history as an area of thought and it has
to do with archeology in the primarily I
mean in the 19th century but going back
to the 18th century when Europeans went
to Egypt in the Middle East and started
to dig things up and take them home they
could have gone to the Yucatan and dug
up and taken home things from a Mayan
pyramid except that it was covered with
trees and vines the nice thing about the
Middle East was that there wasn't any
nasty ground cover and so you could see
you know often when people think of
archaeology they think Oh an
archaeologist went out and he found a
mound and he escalated it there are
about a million mounds in the Middle
East they're all over the place you
travel long in a car in Iran or Iraq or
something and you see this irregular
landscape where you have mounds
presumably there's something underneath
the mountain there's no trouble finding
amount the the trouble is deciding which
mound to dig getting permission to dig
up and putting up with the experience of
having there be nothing of interest
there an archeologist friend of mine who
died a number of years back said that
throughout his career he felt he was
always about three feet away from
becoming world famous that if he just
dug a little bit differently he would
have found the earliest something
inscribed plaque something like that he
never found it he was
very distinguished archaeologists but he
never made the big find and he said that
the amazing thing is that some
archaeologists make may have made the
big find again and again and again and
the question of why some people were
successful and others were journeyman
you know it raises questions I was in
Iran in 1971 and I wanted to go out and
search for long forgotten buried
Buddhist monasteries which may have
existed I don't know I never I never
found any idea theory but I had a good
friend who you know an army u.s. army
intelligence who had leave time and a
government truck and so we went out
camping in the desert going to villages
looking for the stuff and we were
driving along and he said well what are
we going to be leaving for I said I'm
looking for mounds
he said yeah well what what does that
mean so well it'll be a pile of Earth
that doesn't fit said well let's next
time you see one let's stop said oh no
we're still hundreds of miles from here
we're going so we have it it's my car
and I'm driving so when you see a mound
let's stop so only about two three hours
from Tehran on a fairly major road not
the most major road the sort of the
second road I said okay there's a mound
that's really close to the road like you
know 30 metres off the highway so let's
stop and so we walk over to the to the
mound and we're looking around and when
I pick up this
this is a five-pointed star pecked out
of apparently granite has no hole in the
center but it is exactly the shape of a
fourth millennium VC mace head except of
the mace head should have a hole in the
center so he could put up you know a
stick of it and make it a club in the
last 30 years I have not found any
archaeologists who can tell me what this
is
there was pottery there that was
appeared to me to be around 2000 BC now
sort of yeah 2000 BC and that that must
be about right but it was you know hand
thrown thought straw temporary bitumen
blind pottery and and there was it was a
mound it may have been a very very early
mount or may not but what are you going
to do of course you can put this in your
pocket and take it away and violate
iranian antiquities laws so this is an
illegal theft from the from the iranian
people on the other hand the iranian
publishers ignore international royalty
international copyright law so they
translate my books without paying a
royalty and i steal their their stone
star in violation of their law so i have
no i have no negative conscience in all
this
but the point is that there are there
are lots and lots of sites in the last
30 or 40 years fewer and fewer sites
have been dug and more have simply been
been surveyed and a survey work has been
very enlightening because it helps you
choose which one to dig and there are a
number of theories particularly central
place theory that give you ways to try
and analyze what are the places you
should dig and one of the places that
would be less relevant but of course
then you have to have permission now in
the nineteenth century
you simply went and you stole whatever
you found you got permission from a
governor perhaps but you took whole
temples off to European museums and so
on an archaeologist nor less by
contemporary and Iran told me that there
was a village in Iran where he had
examined a an Akkadian inscription on a
stone very rare to find Akkadian
inscriptions in the iranian highlands
and the villagers said that a couple
years earlier some japanese and a Range
Rover Rover had come to the village and
ordered the villagers to put the stone
in the truck and the villagers said no
so the Japanese drove off but you know a
hundred years earlier that would have
worked they could have taken it back to
Tokyo and be in nice Museum there the
result is that where the excavations are
done is a function of the politics the
the geography the degree of safety for
people working in a particular area and
that all converged very nicely upon
Egypt and Mesopotamia and lo and behold
where you were able to they
most easily is where you end up deciding
civilizations started now this has
become an ironic because one of the
great problems of the master narrative
that dates the beginning of civilization
to Egypt and Mesopotamia as the people
in Egypt and Mesopotamia were not
European white people this this was a
big problem back in the 19th century
because racialist theories of superior
and inferior peoples were were very
widespread and had a big popular
following and indeed one of the products
of of this was a distinction between on
the part of certain archaeologists
between people who lived in the Tigris
Euphrates valley in Iraq whom they
thought were white and people living in
Egypt we just didn't seem as white as
the people in Iraq so they came up with
a theory that white people from Iraq
came to the Nile Valley and brought
civilization with them in their grip it
and you had quite a bit Witten on this
question of a so-called conquering white
race of civilized people who went
different places this is also when they
thought they went from Greece to England
to tell people to build Stonehenge that
sort of thing oh all of this racialist
stuff has pretty much been been
discarded but the narrative of Western
civilization has still been burdened by
the by the idea that the origins of
civilization that we see is the roots of
our Western civilization they go back to
parts of the world that we don't longer
include in our Western civilization
namely Egypt and Iraq
wouldn't it have been better if the
earliest civilization had been in Europe
now how cool would that be then the
Europeans could say you know we're at
the origin point of civilization now
that happens to be true
it appears that let's say if you go back
to 4000 BC or 3800 BC which is a good
500 years before the earliest things
that we call cities in Iraq the
beginnings of Sumerian civilization the
largest human settlement in the world
apparently was in Rumania made up
entirely of gymnast it's amazing now it
was it was it was in Romania very much
in the valley not of the Tigris and
Euphrates or the Nile but of the Danube
River and this civilization you know you
had one community there that is
estimated have had 5000 inhabitants
about double the size of the Sumerian
cities when they come to be built and in
sort of great arts of houses that seem
to be organized in a certain form but
this wasn't known back when Lee and the
theory is being established now this
civilization is recognized and is called
old Europe you will not find any
reference to Old Europe
in Chapter one of the earth and its
people's not my fault that I didn't
draft that chapter
but our ancient historian felt that you
know how do you tell the story of the
great river valley civilizations that
give rise to civilization if you have to
start with Romania because the
civilization in Romania old Europe is
dead by 3500 BC instead of it going on
and giving rise to empires and codes of
law and religions and so forth and so on
it began it flourished it ended and it
was in a river valley which which is
very you erased great problem because
the the standard narrative requires the
reader to believe that civilization
once it starts is kind of self
propagating and you can see it's spread
and you can see it increase in
complexity so what was going on in Old
Europe and why didn't we know of course
we go back to the 19th century and you
look at the areas that were involved
which were primarily
Romania Bulgaria and of the southern
most parts of Ukraine this was a very
unsettled and warlike period is a period
of the decline of the Ottoman Empire
rise of very parochial nationalisms
among the various peoples of Southeast
Europe it really wasn't a good time to
simply go out with a shovel and start
digging up in someone's village so that
was one reason perhaps that people never
noticed this civilization there it also
be the question of if you found
something how did you get permission to
to take it to your Museum because who
who was the government the government
and that could be a problem it turns out
that Old Europe was not suspected to
exist as a civilization until the Soviet
period following World War two
between the end of World War two and the
end of the of the Soviet Union there was
a massive archaeological Enterprise in
Southeast Europe Russia southern Russia
and Ukraine to dig up mounds there are
zillions of mounds in that area just
like the Middle East but they hadn't
been dug up before there you know there
wasn't any any tradition that there had
once been a civilization there and when
they were dug up the findings were
published in Russian and Romanian and
published by local academies of Sciences
in books and articles that were not read
by Western archaeologists they also were
books and articles that were predicated
upon Marxist theories of the development
of human society which were very
different from those that prevailed
among Western archaeologists so when the
Soviet Union fell there was a particular
time in place where a handful of
archaeologists were invited from Russia
to come to an archaeological convention
in the United States and to talk about
what they and their colleagues have been
doing for the last two generations and
lo and behold they said we have found a
civilization that is incredibly complex
and that has the oldest layers going
back to well before parallel
developments that you have in Egypt and
in Mesopotamia but it came to an end
even then this did not have the impact
that it might have had if all the
writings had had been translated into
Western languages is if they weren't
that many archaeologists working in the
West who could read Russian excavation
reports you also I had to have the
freedom to go to the site and go to the
museums and look at the collections so
it is only now that the the great
accumulation of archaeological knowledge
from the Soviet era is being melded into
the thinking of of European
archaeologists one of the leading
centers for for publicizing this is the
center for the study of the ancient
world at NYU and they had an exhibition
last spring of the archaeology of old
Europe and a number of publications are
related that this is run the center is
run by our former colleague here at
Columbia Roger Bagnall ah but the
easiest place to get access to this is a
book by David Anthony called uh doesn't
called the name that David Anthony gave
it whore language horses
anyway I'll get it for you and Nathan
will email it to you it's a stunning
book because it tells you that
everything you thought you knew about
the beginnings of civilization has to be
modified how long it will take for it to
trickle down into textbooks I don't know
but when it does it will raise the
question of why the the growth of dense
human settlements based on grain and
grain agriculture did not succeed in
perpetuating itself in Southeast Europe
while it did in Egypt and Mesopotamia
not only that but it turns out that how
old Europe has roots that go back or
outshoot offshoots I should say that go
up the Danube River toward further into
Europe as you move east across the
northern edge of the Black Sea let's say
here's the Black Sea and here's the
Caspian Sea here's the Caucasus
Mountains you've got a little connection
here and here's the Aegean Sea the
connects to the Mediterranean Sea there
are great great issues having to do with
this with this area one of them is the
hydrology of the area the Danube flows
into the Black Sea then the Kenya the
gesture flows into the Black Sea
then the Boog then the de Knepper then
the dawn and you have a whole bunch and
then over here
the Volga and the Ural these rivers flow
from north to south across Central Asia
and Russia and Ukraine and empty into
the Caspian Sea and the Black Sea that
was not always the case it appears that
when you go back to two glacial times
when northern Europe was buried under
under vast quantities of ice these
rivers didn't flow in this direction
it's when you get the melting of the ice
witches around 12,000 BC the last ice
age that the the weight of the ice as it
melts the disappearance that weight
allows the land to sort of spring back
and so these rivers start to flow into
the Black Sea and the Caspian and larger
amounts but during the Ice Age the the
sea level fell so much that the Black
Sea was not connected with the world's
oceans and in fact the Black Sea appears
to have been a very fairly shallow lake
if you go back further into the ice ages
you'll find that the Mediterranean Sea
was almost dry when you look at cross
sections of the Nile Valley you see that
you know here you have the Nile flows in
the Mediterranean but if you look at the
cross section you find that at one time
so flowing into the sea here flowing
through a very deep canyon to get down
to the level of the Mediterranean Sea
because the Mediterranean Sea was almost
dry and what you have now
places like Cyprus and Crete Sicily
Islands and Mediterranean were once
mountaintops
and it helps explain why you have
certain species of animals that get
isolated on these islands and are left
over from the time when you could walk
across the area that becomes
Mediterranean Sea so you got like dwarf
elephants and cypress elephants were
stranded on what became an island and
gradually became you know three or four
feet tall instead of twelve feet tall
but that was that was long long ago the
issue of the Mediterranean and the RIT
and the Black Sea may go back to around
5,000 BC in other words within the same
very broad time horizon of when the old
European civilization came into being
and you have different theories to
scholars at the lamont-doherty Earth
Observatory the Columbia Center for
studying oceanography and
all aspects of geology that's located
across the river just north of the
George Washington Bridge to scholars
there Pittman and his colleague the
gentleman who is not Pittman they wrote
a book called Noah's Flood I remember
some titles Noah's Flood says that
sometime around maybe 5500 BC the
something happened that allowed the
water from the Aegean and the
Mediterranean to break through at this
level and to fill the Black Sea and
their argument is that that great
filling of the bathtub is what came in
legend to be called Noah's Flood because
at the time that the Black Sea was
filling up
on the northern edges of the Black Sea
you had people who were growing wheat
and barley on on low low-lying land and
they gradually were flooded out and they
all had to leave there's a very
controversial thesis you have some
people who hold to it very strongly on
the number of technical grounds and some
people who dispute it on technical
grounds of a similar argument saying
that something here called the Caspian
depression at one point the Caspian Sea
of the Black Sea were we're linked
together and then the sea levels changed
and the link between them disappeared so
there's a lot of controversy unlike the
Nile where there is broad agreement that
that is the river and that's where the
river has been and that's where the
river is going to stay and you could
pretty much count on there being a Nile
River there it doesn't mean that there
weren't other rivers in North Africa is
just that all the others dried up and
only the Nile survived if you the
dryness of North Africa the dryness of
the Sahara Desert reached if the maximum
at which it is still situated around
2500 BC before that it was moisture and
any and instead of having desert from
Egypt to the Atlantic Ocean
you had grassland and in some areas
probably a savanna forest if you fly
over the Sahara Desert you can see the
river valleys in the most dramatic way
you can say ah there was a great
waterfall
there's where two rivers flow together
when you see now is simply rivers of
sand water is all disappeared but the
Nile because it connected with why
resources in central Africa denial
survive same thing with the Tigers new
freight ease the Tigers new freight ease
have been there
changing their beds some what over
thousands of years but by and large they
have been there all the way along and
the water there unlike in the Nile where
comes from Central Africa the water
there comes from the snowfall in Turkey
that melts and flows into the Tigris and
Euphrates valleys that go through Turkey
Syria and Iraq and end up in the Persian
Gulf
now that hydrology in other words is one
where you can say we know where the
rivers were and we can see the whole
area getting drier over time but up here
it's it's controversial you know what
constituted a river system or an
agricultural system along a lake was the
water in the lake
sweet water or say line what is the the
situation there the linkage between Old
Europe and the broad hydrology of the
region hasn't really been been
thoroughly worked out at this time
however old Europe is from here over and
to save from the Don River to the
westward none of that wheat and barley
cultivation extends over here and when
you get over here Central Asia
east of the Volga River and the Ural
River you don't even get any people to
speak up cadenza very just foragers so
there was a clustering in this direction
and where these various river valleys
were and that is where the old European
civilization located as I say if
if this had been known in the 19th
century European historians fixated upon
the history of Western civilization
would have said civilization began with
white Europeans in Romania and was
borrowed by the Egyptians and the
Mesopotamians who really weren't quite
plain enough to qualify as Europeans
this kind of thinking is linked to a to
a school of theorizing known as
diffusion ISM diffusion ISM is based on
the idea that it is more likely that
something will happen once and spread
then that it will happen in a similar or
identical fashion in different places
that are not connected with each other
one of the is one of the great areas of
a controversy both in archaeology and in
history is what do you do when you see a
phenomenon that occurs in different
areas the diffusion as' usually say that
there must be a single point of origin
and that everything spreads from there
this is really why we have this this
concept of Western Civ up to Mesopotamia
is that the earliest place has to be the
place from which everything else spread
we don't go it's not used methodically
in other words if you take much more
recent things you can say oh the
but the computer was invented the West
and diffused from the West to transform
the rest of the world but then when you
say well gunpowder was invented in China
and diffused from China to the rest of
the world then you say the really
important thing isn't where gunpowder
was invented it's what the people who
borrowed it did with it because again
there's a effort to sort of give special
attention and special primacy to what
the Europeans did but when you go to
this earlier period diffusion ISM is a
very a very difficult issue to deal with
some things clearly diffused and the
most obvious ones are plants and animals
that show up in geographical spaces
where they are not indigenous they had
to get there somehow and if those plants
and animals are domestic the presumption
is that they came in conjunction with
humans
so horses are not native to China are
not native to the Middle East are not
native to Southeast Asia but they show
up in those places and so you can talk
about the diffusion of horse culture in
some sense
similarly wheat and barley are not
native to northern China the grains
initially you know grown there were
local grains foxtail millet and pearl
millet not wheat and barley but they
come there so you can look at products
that move from one place to another and
there's a great deal of of scholarship
devoted to this
movement of plants and animals on the
other hand in the area of domestication
the the tendency now is to argue that
certain species are domesticated in more
than one place it's it's an argument you
can't prove it very well you can you can
prove through DNA analysis that let us
say all dogs belong to the same species
but there's a huge argument over whether
all dogs descend from you know from Adam
dog and Eve dog who were first you know
brought as puppies into the house by you
know some cave lamb dogs are problematic
where they the best they become domestic
in several different locales or in one
and if in one why do the divides of the
function of dogs seem to differ there is
very little support for the idea the
dogs you know become domestic animals
because they help it hunting this is the
standard notion when you have the idea
that hunters go to herders now that
generally is not accepted some people
would argue that dogs were became
domestic because they were good to eat
and in certain parts of the world dog is
really a choice food you know dog
restaurants in Korea render great
pressure at the time of the World Cup
there because you have the globalists in
Korea saying we have to close the dog
restaurants because it'll gross out you
know everyone else and the Korean saying
no no our national pride demands that we
keep the dog restaurant open well you
know you can still get dog in Korea it's
supposed to be very very good I haven't
had any but and nobody suggested that
you know there should be dietary changes
on the other part of the world because
of the World Cup or the Olympics or
something of that sort but but we don't
know about dogs cats another problematic
animal unlike dogs there is a fairly
strong argument that's made that cats
were domesticated in became domestic in
one place
probably Egypt and not a terribly long
time ago the number of chromosomal
differences that you have in caps from
wild cat for the most closely related
wild cat to the domestic cat is
negligible with both dogs and cats you
have a theory that is called self
domestication which maintains that under
certain circumstances some animals will
seek out living with humans
those circumstances are primarily
related to first in the case of dogs -
all of the leftover food from the
animals of the humans killed in the
Paleolithic and Mesolithic period that
there were just you know heaps of you
know juicy bones that the humans really
couldn't eat very well you know as long
and and you could just go there and eat
those bones like a bear going to a
garbage dump and if the humans thought
you were dangerous they would kill you
and eat you but if they thought you were
safe they would let you stay because you
were policing up the campsite that's
fear yourself to investigation for for
dogs nobody knows whether it's correct
or not self-sufficient desmith
domestication for cats maintains that in
Egypt perhaps elsewhere but Egypt is the
most likely
when you had grain agriculture people
started to collect large quantities of
grain and store it and where they stored
large quantities of grain they attracted
large quantities of mice and where they
had large quantities of mice they had
large quantities of cats because the
cats preferred to eat the mice or
anything else so they didn't say let's
live in this human encampment they said
let's live in Mouse apples you know
let's just go in there like Godzilla and
eat every Mouse we can find because
they're just scurrying around all over
the place and we're we're the cats we
mice now the humans as hypothetically
with the dogs would kill the cats if
they felt they were dangerous no scratch
my baby I bring you no but if the if the
cat was was docile they would permit it
to live because it was clearing out the
mice and this gets into the crucial
issue of the definition of what is a
domestic animal and which I've talked
about in what I was saying for you to
read by my definition a domestic animal
is an animal that belongs to a
population of a given species in which
you have docility inherited from
generation to generation has nothing to
do with taming animals or you know
getting puppies or cubs and raising them
among humans it has to be inherited so
that you go from generation to
generation and each generation is as
docile and the way that occurs in the
experimental studies that have been done
in the 20th century is that
if you take a population of wild animals
and you force them to hang around with
people so that there are people over the
place or in the cage and a lab or
something like that
most of the wild animals will not be
able to have sex
they'll just be too anxious la OH
who's looking you know oh Jesus yeah
there's Bob again looking you know they
they just won't do it so in the early
20th century took a hundred rats 80% of
them did not reproduce because their
fight-or-flight reaction with respect to
to reproduction was so high that they
were agitated all the time and the only
ones that reproduce were the sort of
stoners the the laid-back rats said oh
all right Bob
yeah cool I'll watch you too you know
it's you know the next generation had a
higher proportion of those that have the
laid-back fight-or-flight reactions
because most of the parents were in that
subset of the natural distribution of
hormonal stimuli by the time you get to
twenty or thirty generations you have a
population that has adrenaline glands
that are seventy five percent smaller
than those of the wild population and
they no longer run away they no longer
become startled they no longer have any
difficulty reproducing they are docile
and interestingly enough they look
different this has not been fully
analyzed but they were certain that as
you
change the hormonal balance there are
certain physical changes that that occur
one of them is albinism that almost all
domestic animals in the early stages of
education start to have white spots here
and there like on the forehead or
something like that pig a cow a horse a
dog a white blaze on the forehead is an
early appears to be associated with
domestication pure white animals some of
them of course like polar bears are
obviously environmentally influenced but
pure white animals are more likely than
not to be domestic so domestic rabbits
are white wild rabbits are not domestic
geese are white wild geese are not
domestic ducks are white wild ducks are
not Donald Duck is domestic
Daffy Duck is wild it's you know and one
of the big challenges to Judaism
whatever happened to the white mice I
mean here you had Mickey he was black
and somehow they should have gotten
white mice into that story but they
never did anyway so the development of
of a domestic population has more to do
with the continuous breeding over
numerous generations in a particular
locale or restricted area in which the
the most wild offspring were killed or
driven away and the most docile ones
were kept until you had a population
that was essentially all docile and this
seems to apply to a whole bunch of
animals although it may have come about
in different ways according to different
specific species but the thing is it's
not the fusion
the the older work done with
domesticating animals as with plants
said that once somebody figured out how
to how to domesticate an animal then
they can go and domesticate another
animal of course they never did figure
out how to investigate an animal you
let's say you have domestic a domestic
cow and you think of thirty generations
you say gee 300 years ago that was a
wild cow good thing we kept careful
records it was public of course they
didn't keep careful as they didn't know
what was happening domestication in most
cases I believe is an unanticipated
outcome that isn't even recognized
necessarily when it has occurred there
are other theories lady Strauss for
example famous structuralist
anthropologist maintained that prior to
the Neolithic Revolution humans had a
scientific spirit and were avid
experimentalists and they thought they
simply experimented with keeping animals
and crossbreeding them just to see what
happened and then as soon as they got a
domestic animal then they quit being
scientists and they became barbecue
mavens they you know he he argued that
there was a primitive scientific
mentality that disappears in the
Neolithic and does not reappear until
the modern scientific revolution I think
that's wrong but
lady Strauss is very famous so what can
I do I won't you know be as harsh on him
as I will and Jared Diamond who no
manners has got almost everything wrong
um okay so you have this this problem of
diffusion ISM we have a master narrative
that says that the Queen and barley will
begin to be domesticated wheat and
barley show up in the Nile Valley and
Mesopotamia and they spread from there
if you go to the website for Jared
Diamond's books book Guns Germs and
Steel you will actually have an animated
map that will show here's where wheat
and barley start and they sprint and
here's where potatoes start to let no no
potatoes no yams no corn no anything
just wheat and barley because that's the
whole story
diffusion is emizner on sense but it has
to be you know looked at very carefully
when it comes to the question of Old
Europe this is a hot debate one of the
dominant theories about the end of Old
Europe by one of the first
archaeologists to to show that this had
been a dynamic civilization by 4000 BC
Maria Jim butis she said that this
civilization was destroyed by
horse-riding mace wielding you know
chariot driving warriors from from the
east
and of course there's a corollary that
Old Europe is seen in this theory as
being matriarchal that because we have
many many little figurines thousands of
little figurines of a pregnant or at
least overweight females and then we
stop having those so it's the idea that
the beastly heavily-armed
testosterone driven men and their
chariots and horses came in to destroy
the peace-loving matriarchal women of
Southeast Europe who had actually
created civilization and then they it
got stolen from them because that's just
what men do you know that they're just
beastly um well you know David Anthony
who's written the book the name of which
I can't remember goes into this argument
in quite some detail because he's
particularly interested in the origin of
of these horse riders and chariot
drivers and particularly of the relation
of horse riding and chariot driving to
the indo-european languages and this
goes into another chapter in this sort
of big history story of you have
archaeology you have study of bones of
implements of climate change and you
have language and this is one of the
hardest things to to deal with in a
world historical context because to
study language it kind of means you have
to know some language and generally we
can make no assumptions about foreign
languages in particular there's a
question of when does language arise
and why does it get divided up of
geographically and by social group in
the way that it comes to be divided up I
know okay power of Babel that explains
it all but it really is a problem and
it's a problem that relates to not
simply the surviving evidence of
language and language difference but
also to scientific theories about how
language comes to be produced
now here the most controversial argument
has been that that syntax the ability to
link sounds together in a meaningful
fashion which is seen to be essential to
define a language that syntax comes
about because of a genetically
established capacity of the human brain
that no other animal has and this is the
idea of a syntax gene or a language gene
of know'm tramps key is the primary
author of this theory who was
almost unquestionably the most famous
and brilliant American scholar of
linguistics before he switched to two
left-wing polemic writing where he is
now America's perhaps foremost and most
brilliant writer of left-wing
palomeque's but nevertheless Chomsky's
notion of the language gene encountered
the question of the physical capacity to
to create - to create language in other
words the the great apes who are our
closest relatives do not have a physical
capacity - to create linguistic sounds
or modulate them in their throat of
their lips and so forth to create speech
so at some point you have a physical
capacity that comes into being and
according to Chomsky at some point you
have a a genetic capacity to make use of
the physical capacity now one could
argue that the physical capacity to make
the sounds must have come first because
it would be sort of silly to have a
syntax gene say you know I really want
to recite the Iliad out
[Music]
oh if you couldn't make the sounds so
that's why had a conversation with one
of our anthropologists who's made his
reputation on studies of the brain and
the physiology of the of the skull and
and we talked about this and he said
well chimpanzees can have the physical
capacity to hum have the physical
capacity to hum but they don't and and
that was sort of interesting you know
[Music]
bananas mm-hmm but but they don't choose
to as if you say well there was a
physical capacity but the the will
wasn't there then you get to the debate
over Neanderthals the Oh humans from
before 40,000 BC
could they speak and you get
disagreements on that one of the
interesting findings of archaeology in
Neolithic a Neanderthal sites has been a
small number of flutes first there was
one and two now there have been several
these are bones that are perforated with
the perforations spaced in such a way
that you could play it as a flute
initially